welcome to led live i am
really excited about the topic today
we're going to be answering the question
is our choice in music really that big
of a deal find out on this episode of
led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness welcome everyone
to the show this is led live the show
where we use the light of christ to
expose the darkness found in media and
our culture today
and today to help us share is my mom
florence calendar i call her mama
calendar
and she's coming all the way from new
york and she's really done a lot of
research in this topic of music
so i'm really excited to hear what you
have to say nice to me let's jump right
into it
well yeah let's jump right in i have an
activity for you guys
i love it as you think back to the
creation of the world
put these things in order in terms of
how they originated
we have angels we have
marriage we have music
and the sabbath what do you think came
first what is next and next and
next oh i would guess angels first
okay do we all have to go by scotty's
okay so you want to discuss it well
i i would think maybe a sabbath okay
the sabbath do you want to take a vault
sabbath came first sabbath was made for
man well
god's law is eternal right and the
angels aren't even eternal
that is an interesting principle that
would get us onto a completely different
topic
yes god's law is eternal but what was
god's law that is eternal
that's the question is it that there
were ten commandments written in stone
or is it that there is a principle at
work
that is god's law that goes through
i think we should put a timer on this
well the sabbath
they they weren't supposed to pick up
manna on the sabbath and that was before
the ten commandments were given
we're talking creation here in terms
of the origin okay yeah
okay well i mean the angels existed
before the sabbath yeah i mean it was a
constant worship
right okay so you want to go with with
um scotty's one yeah
yuri okay so angels first what's next
because this was instituted
okay okay he says music next what's next
uh um um mary i'm real close on this but
um i'm tempted to flip these two i'm
just trying to think
like is there a verse that i can think
of
that would make music come before angels
but i i would almost agree with keith i
think these
two could potentially be swapped just
due to
we don't know if if you know god is
eternal has always existed
but he's at some point created something
i don't i don't know if any other bean
can have that that same kind of
you know they've always been around so
at some point he brought the angels into
existence and created them
and i just figure since god is the
originator of music
that he maybe was musical prior to the
creation of the angels
so i i'm actually going to change my
there's two yeah i mean okay so that's
true
what about the others i'll go with yeah
that sounds good trying to think of a
biblical basis for that but yeah it
makes sense because all of a sudden it's
like you create new
angels and they're like hey what are we
doing god's like hey i got music you
know right
right okay it's like wait a minute so i
come back to
your order in a little bit but first
visit our brothers at school for
prophets.tv and watch from babylon to
america which has over 5 million views
on youtube alone
and follow it up with america 2 babylon
check the description below for links to
this and more
let's look at the bibles that's what
you're looking for
the first mention of music in the bible
actually is in the lineage of
cain and that's a lineage of rebellion
so
in itself that gives us a
caution it's a red flag for caution it's
a warning
and that's in genesis chapter 4 verse 21
where it says
and his brother's name was jubal he was
the father of
all such as hand over harp and the organ
so the scripture also tells us that
music was given as a gift
to lucifer and that's a clue right there
when he was created and we find that
text in ezekiel 28 13.
the workmanship of thy tablets or
timbrels and pipes
was prepared in the the day that thou
was
created now the old testament takes us
back
even before lucifer and in each of its
sections the law
the writings and the prophets we are
told that god is our strength
our song and salvation amen
so music predated lucifer lucifer
is an angel you guys get it yeah so
not only is god our song he also
sings so zephaniah 3 17
says the lord thy god in the midst of
thee is mighty
he will save he will rejoice over you
with joy he will rest in his love he
will
joy with sing over thee with singing i
wonder what like god's
singing voice sounds like it really
inquires at once
yeah you know highest soprano lowest
bass yeah
we can't even imagine it says higher
than our highest human thoughts can
think
you know so what does all of this tell
us music
is from god so your order here
is actually correct music was first
because it originated with god and god
is eternal
then he created angels of which
music was an important part in the main
the chief
angel lucifer then when the creation
week happened marriage was created right
before the sabbath
so that's the order so then what is
music
i would say venture to say it's an
expression of
maybe how you feel or you know if you
i don't know if you just listening to
that verse that you just read is
as the lord singing over you you know
it's like he's expressing his
feelings for you okay artistic way to an
artistic way to get out
uh a message like poetry
is or writing a love letter sometimes
people are like
i can't say how i feel but i can write
it in a song or something
i would say music is sound okay
what about you no i mean i don't think i
have anything to add to all that that
was all good
so your descriptions of music is music
as
the noun the thing music is also
a verb so as a verb
music means it comes from the root word
muse and muse referred to a god or
goddess
in greek mythology it also means to
control
thoughts or to make think
so by its very definition music is
designed to control the way people
think you can see that in society too
i can attest to that um just being a
creative when i edit
if if i actually have a piece of music
that inspires me
i see a different way of piecing
together those pieces of video
and changing the music actually changes
the way that i would actually line those
up
very good yeah and music is powerful
it's more powerful than
speech and you actually remember what
you
sing better than you remember what you
say
i don't know about you guys but when i
was in elementary school
i learned the times tables by singing
them
because i found those things the most
boring of all why do i need to learn
this stuff
and so the only way i could have learned
them was by singing
you're going to grace us with an example
right yeah one time
i think all of the time stable songs are
just about the same
and some of them really are more
chanting than singing
it's not like a melody running through
it's more like chanting but it
has the the beat and the rhythm that
keeps that keeps your mind going
and so that's how i learned it didn't
any of you have a similar experience
or was i the only one who needed music
to know about stop labels but
that you learn your abcs with the song
okay we often use that as an example i'm
like it seems like it would be
tough to because it doesn't really rhyme
or anything but
i have noticed that songs will stick in
your head even when you don't want them
there
i mean i i spent like two days hearing
something about uh
this christmas song about i want a
hippopotamus for christmas i
would not leave my head driving me
insane and
you know i i didn't put it there my
daughter um my they
my daughter and my son they go to a
sabbath school where um
the teacher of the sabbath school
actually encourages them to memorize the
the verses
and send them videos and if they do that
every single week of them like
in their memorization at the end of the
quarter she she brings them
a a gift and i think it's really neat
she actually actually drives to each of
the children's houses with this box
and it's like the kids and they're not
like little meager gifts either
but what i have observed it's
interesting my daughter
she's kind of musical and she quickly
made up songs
to remember the bible verses and you
could still go to her today and and say
what what what does this bible verse and
she'll sing it to you
and sing it back with like yeah like
like saying every single word so
she's learned that if she just adds a
little tune to it it really does stick
in your brain
allah brings me to my next point did you
know that the largest book in the bible
is
a hymnal it's a book of songs the book
of psalms
has the most men the most chapters in
the bible
and assam is a sacred song or hymn
so the book of psalms is a book of music
and
most of the scripture songs that we sing
come from
the book of psalms one day we'll get to
hear david really tell us
sing it how it's supposed to go he's
like it didn't sound like that oh yeah
that's right we don't have the harp that
he had yeah
yeah so what is another question for you
guys what is the control center of the
body
the brain the brain yeah we agree on
that
frontal lobe well you're really specific
the part of the brain
okay that and that's correct
neuroscientists and musicians
they have explored how music impacts our
brain functions
so if music can impact your brain
function
do you think it influences the body
absolutely yeah yeah because the brain
as we just said is the control center of
the body
now in the medical field it was noted
that
low weight babies when exposed to
healthy music
that they developed more quickly than
babies who were not that's
awesome yeah now like
i don't know if this is true to whatever
but it seems like people in the medical
field
they can play like a cello or a piano
like amazingly
so is it just because they're incredibly
intelligent or is it
that they played the music which made
them
incredibly intelligent to go become a
doctor
i didn't i never put those together i
mean if you go to loma linda
and you hear some of these medical
students it's like they play the piano
like they practice it eight hours a day
and it's like aren't you
in medical school like they started that
way before medical school yeah
yeah but it also may apply to
other industries if you go look at the
people who are exceptional
in the work that they do a lot of them
also play musical instruments
like opens up the mind in a way yes
there is there is a connection between
playing music
and and cognitive performance
there is one you mentioned babies like
responding positively to music
and god being a musical being i remember
reading a study but years ago so i hope
it's still like i say it accurately
but a scientist like un wound
a dna strand and the the
is it the rna that was on the the strand
or the dna is actually like notes
and he could like play a tune specific
to each individual i was like whoa
that's that's pretty cool wow
like we all have our own sound right
yeah that's interesting music is
actually imprinted in our bodies yeah
yeah
and actually um the auditory
nerve ending the auditory system has
more nerve endings over your entire body
than any other sensory system
wow so that just gives you a little hint
there about how we'll be affected by
music
now in the the brunette on honors
college
there is a subject called music
and the brain and there there's a tag
team of teachers a neuroscientist
and a violinist and one of the things
they teach their students
with that is that people who have
neurodegenerative diseases like
alzheimer's and
parkinson's they actually respond
positively to music
so usually with alzheimer's in its late
stages those people are really
non-responsive but what they found is if
they put headphones
on them and they play usually snippets
of their favorite music
then their eyes light up and they
actually
start moving and sometimes even singing
and
that effect will last up to like 10
minutes after the music is turned off
i've heard that i've also heard that
people who have a really bad stutter
can sing without stuttering yes they do
and i can tell you that for a fact as a
speech pathologist
yes that's right so when when children
most children when they read
and when they sing they do not stutter
if you have a child who stutters when
he or she is reading you know the
stuttering is really profound
so is it more because they're trying to
think of what to say but if they're
reading it that's already there
or well it has to do with the rhythm our
brain has rhythm
whether whether we say we can sing a
tune or not your brain has rhythm and
every
every cell in your body has rhythm
and so it because it's not
it's not um voluntary you don't have to
think about it it just comes
naturally then the stuttering which
comes
because you're afraid you're going to
make a mistake on this sound or that
sound
that's that's really very voluntary so
it removes that component okay i think
it's interesting if you look over the
history of
how man has used music i mean we use it
in such a
wide variety of ways when we would go to
war there would be somebody in there you
know like
playing music and these terrible things
are happening
and then you know to heal somebody with
music and i mean there's such a wide
variety of
of uses for it yeah and we are going to
come down to the the
instruments a little later so
if our the human body can be controlled
and altered
by music the scientists are saying that
that happens because
music actually changes the brain by
creating new pathways
so it changes the neural pathways or the
nerve pathways in the brain
and by so doing it creates changes in
the body
and in fact we actually have mri images
that show when music is played
the brain lights up in many different
parts unlike
other things that it will light up one
part of the brain or the other part of
the brain
music is just it goes all over the brain
so in terms of human physiology and
anatomy
and many aspects of health there are
lots of medical studies
that actually show us how music is used
to affect health changes like to lower
blood pressure
to treat mental illness to treat
mental retardation to treat people with
insomnia
and many others would that be very
specific on what type of music
is played though i mean like i could
imagine some types of music raise the
blood pressure yeah
i was just thinking if there's any
skeptics you know just
listen to some horror music or something
it's not going to give you a pleasant
feeling
right yeah okay so that leads me to my
next point
where i just said that music creates
these neural changes and it results in
functional
outcomes there's one of the studies
there are many studies but in the
wisconsin study
they showed that joyful music produced
an
increase in blood flow and that increase
was similar to
aerobic exercise and it was actually
a better result than laughter or
even relaxation that's the power of
music
joyful music now on the other hand the
same study found that the converse was
true
so the power of music can work both ways
so when the selections were once that
triggered anxiety
and you know you can create that with
the instruments that you use
then the listeners produced a decrease
in their blood flow i remember seeing
like a
a a video that like actually like they
hard-boiled an
egg by sticking it in front of a speaker
did you see that
yeah yeah it was like i don't remember
if that was ever scientifically actually
proven
or what about the you know playing
certain types of music to a plant and
the plant like dies as opposed to if you
play it really nice music it thrives
i've seen a mythbusters on that that's
not true not the plant i've seen the
mythbusters on the
egg the egg one because what the whole
thing was that
as the as the music is playing with the
heavy heavy rhythm
and the noise the the protein in the egg
coagulates and so it boils the egg wow
so we have the pearls and the cons with
that interesting
egg yeah right what's it do to your mind
we have protein in our bodies so what's
happening to not just our mind our
entire bodies
so it's not just like the vibration it's
actually the music like it
you couldn't hardly an egg with
classical music music is vibration
yeah but different rhythms give you
different
levels of vibration so i always thought
if you talk to your plants they do
better like i actually tell my plants i
love you you know
thank you for giving me food and just if
it helps but actually
yeah maybe my tomatoes are bigger i
think i think the plant studies are
there's more validation in that there
are children who
did science science experiments
with plants and one that i read some
time ago
this young boy he played three kinds of
music
to music to his plants so he had
classical music
with some plants and then he had
christian music
and then he had rock music and the the
plants with
classical music and christian music
thrived the ones with the christian
music thrived
more than the ones with the classical
music and the plants that
that had the rock music played to them
within three weeks they were dead
no that's interesting to me yeah i mean
it's alive right
i mean you know at some level it's i
don't i don't know
you know probably doesn't understand
what you're saying to it but
yeah even the the wind and sea obey him
that's what the disciples said in awe
to jesus it's like the plans to
recognize the creator
but remember also that music is
vibration
sound is vibration and vibration when it
comes into your body
depending on the level of vibration it's
going to have different effects on our
bodies
and so that that it makes sense to me
having studied sound and its effect on
the body
then i can understand how the heavily
rhythmic music
can actually damage the the body systems
and the cells because they are
perceptive they are what's the word
susceptible to sound waves
so that we were talking about that that
was about how music
affects the body in terms of health well
our emotional health is tied closely to
our physical health so if music affects
the physical health do you think it also
affects the emotional health
yeah yeah we don't feel good our emotion
is down
that's right the answer yeah the answer
is yes and listen to the statement from
the canadian
mental health association they said
mental health and physical health
are fundamentally linked
and there is a a longer quote which will
be
the resource resource guide attached to
this
this um episode so there is a reason
why people play salsa music or merengue
music
for zumba classes and that
in the movies suspense um
type music is played for movies like
jaws
i mean would you play the music from
as a lullaby with your baby to sleep
thank you and i think sometimes we think
oh it's just association you just you've
heard that in horror movies but i i
heard another guy talking about this
subject and he said
uh he played just horror music like
music from a horror movie to his
congregation and like a little
two-year-old like went and grabbed his
mom scared
this kid had never been exposed to
horror movies so for any skeptics that
think it's association
there is something scary about that and
i think it's uh
a lot of it's played like out of tune oh
yeah dissident sounds and like
you know real and you can hear a song
for the first time
that you've never heard this song so
you're not familiar with it and somebody
hits the wrong key and you're just like
right even though you've never heard the
song before you just like that don't fit
you know it brings this raucous sound to
you
because it's out of tune yeah so the
right the right
song can actually create any
desired mood and it can also create the
thoughts
to go with that mood and your thoughts
you
the type of music you play can cause
your thoughts to go in
any of a variety of different directions
and moods so you can use music to make
people
sit down and study you can
use music to make them get up and dance
so
it can make you angry it can make you
sad
and the the power of music music
some types of music just exert
uncontrollable power over the body
i it's it's like so when you hear
certain types of music
you cannot control your body so for
example
if you hear a tango um
can you no can you tango to a raptune
probably not really right yep what about
do a rock and roll dance to a walls
yeah yeah they just just don't go
together and so
that tells us the power that types of
music have
over our body your strong muscles and
your powerful mind
they can't go against the will of the
molecules that are dancing around us
which our brain interprets as sound
wow my younger brother he spent some
time really he thought he wanted to be a
dj in fact he was
he was um he got pretty pretty big in
one of the cities that's close to here
and would always
dj in clubs and stuff and i remember as
i was just
asking him about it he would always tell
me that as the dj you're controlling the
audience
and that there's actually they call it a
set when they put together all their
songs for the night
and there's an actual flow into like you
would a story there's a climax there's a
there's a peaking and then there's a
resolution of that and there's like a
three-act system
that the dj sit down and as they develop
the songs they're actually
like like this song you can't play it
over here it has to go here
and that puts the audience in a certain
trance yeah yeah it's even called
right you know and and there's a method
behind that but i was kind of shocked by
you got you know like i asked him all
the time like you actually said i don't
think about this like
you don't just you know i like the song
and i want to play the song it's like no
there's an order to it load up the
playlist right right
there there's an order to a lot of music
that happens
in places commercial music music you
hear in the elevator
and there's actually a genre of music
called music
music was desired to was designed
to create or to influence buyers
so when you go into stores the music
is played if they want people to leave
the store quickly
it's a different volume and tempo than
if they want you to walk around and
browse and buy more
i mean these things are calculated
they're not happenstance
think about you you you get put on hold
right
what kind of music do you get it's nice
and now some people actually ask you for
your choice of music
or whether you want to listen with music
or in silence
yeah so they're learning yeah and you
know this phenomenon
is even reflected in our vocabulary in
our language
we talk about being moved by the music
that's right
which means it's it's not static it's
dynamic
and it does something to us it moves us
in whichever direction
the the type of music we are listening
to will
so let's look at two effects one
psychological one mental
effects that music can have on us
in the educational cycle circles
researchers have found that when
certain types of classical music usually
by mozart
is played in the background when
students college students
were studying that their learning
performance was enhanced
so that's called the mozart effect i
don't know if you've heard about it
and then in terms of the psychological
effect
music can reduce the symptoms of
depression
and there are studies that have proven
that and in music therapy
it's considered to be a safe and
effective treatment
for a variety of disorders including
depression as well as anxiety in
patients
which i think is really dangerous when
you have depressed
individuals listening to depressive
things like
mode you're you know more into
depression or something
and and you know you obviously maybe you
want to
sit and sulk in your yeah it seems that
people do gravitate towards that
i'm depressed i want to listen to really
angry and you want to just listen like
yeah somebody screaming
that can be bad and you know there there
are studies that show you
the emotions that are evoked by
different kinds of music
and we can put that in the resource the
resource guide also well that makes me
think of david obviously being
invited to play for saul you know he's
crazy and
and and out of his mind and you know
david just by his plane
put him back into you know a rightful
mind
he was playing cast demons out of them
exactly so
if if we look at the duality
of life if if certain types of music can
cast demons out of you
would other kinds of music actually
attract demons to you
i believe so it's something to think
about and something to research right
my son is learning to play piano my
oldest and uh
he's drawn to these minor keys
when he's practicing and he'll be
playing you know moonlight sonata
and he's the type he'll just do it over
and over and over and over and over
again you know my wife's just like
please play something else
it's so minor it's somber
yeah the power of music so you talked
about
um instruments i'm just going to give
you of just three examples
of the emotions that are evoked by
different kinds of of instruments
so for example the horn and the trumpet
is one kind of horn
that can evoke attention alertness
sharpness and you notice that in the
bible every time the trumpet was
was um referenced it was in
in reference to a celebration or
i either going to war or celebrating
victory coming after war
so that's the type of emotions it was
evoking
then you have stringed instruments of
which the violin is one
and those can evoke pain and sorrow
grief sadness as well as excitement
involvement and even anger depending on
how those strings were played
now david played a harp which is a
stringed instrument
and so he was evoking probably
excitement or maybe moving in you know
how you said
the djs arranged music from one to the
other he may have been moving
saul from his grief and his sadness into
excitement that's interesting you know
he he may have been directed
to use his harp in that way and then we
have the orchestra which
is a family of instruments so the
orchestra
actually tells stories in and it
and those stories are felt through
emotional changes of experience
as the orchestra goes through the
various uh changes
in so in tune and song and rhythm and
tempo and all of that
yeah a lot of older cartoons don't even
have talking it's all just
well i think it's such a powerful um a
powerful
genre of music because we still listen
to music from like the 1400s right
i mean people still drive around in
their cars listening to classical music
and and it's stuck around for that long
i mean almost every major
film uses that yeah and so it's a
powerful powerful thing
they're into entire stations that just
play classical music
that's just to tell you how it is so
what neuroscientists have found
is that music triggers the release of
mood altering chemicals in the brain
when these chemicals are released into
the body
the mood changes before we move on to
that i remember having this discussion
with candy
when we were kind of observing kanye
west coming out
and do you remember that clip that you
showed me i think it was
where kanye west when he was coming out
of producing
worldly type music and then he's all of
a sudden turning christian
and going into the church and he says i
didn't want this and this and this drum
and he even named
like the different types of instruments
that he did not want in that
in that worship service and to me that
was telling of like wow here's a
here's a musician who understands like
exactly what music is going to do
for you and put you in that mood or
whatever and he was saying this is not
appropriate in this setting and i
thought that was
that was a powerful clip to observe that
it is
and that's actually a topic for a whole
other discussion
because different drums have different
rhythms attached to them and they bring
different
results based on the drumming and
syncopation
and and the polyrhythm that the the um
layering of rhythms one on another
and they get the results that they want
when they use those drums
so that's a whole another study that'll
be part two
that's right yeah so um
while music can certainly impact uh our
moods
the type of music is important which we
have been bringing out in our discussion
now according to research classical and
meditative music
offer the greatest mood boosting results
while heavy metal rock and techno music
have been proved to have been proven to
be ineffective
and even detrimental to the body systems
we've talked about the two extremes here
we've gone classical which is i guess
like
the purest of musics and then you have
heavy metal and rock which is
the most detrimental what about like in
the middle like
brandy r b or like kirk franklin music
or like kenny g jazz you know like
where does that fall so just as you have
a spectrum
with most things so when we talk about
classical music would be on the spectrum
of on the end of the spectrum
in terms of beneficial music mood
boosting music
good thinking good thoughts music on the
other end you have the heavy
metal of the rock and the techno music
which is detrimental it gives you dark
thoughts and
anger the other kinds of music fall
on along the spectrum and so
some of them would be close to classical
and as you move
up on on the list the type of music they
get
closer to the heavy metal and the rock
music
there is a spectrum how much do you
think actually the creation of the music
you know you often hear an artist puts
themselves
so much into the music and that when you
listen to their music you're actually
taking on
sort of the spirit that they created it
in
um i mean i'm just thinking off the top
of my head i remember there was a
musician back in the 90s i think her
name was tori amos
and she had been abused and she wrote a
lot of that into her music and it wasn't
necessarily like
heavy metal or rock or anything like
that but but i mean it was just like you
could
feel her and your
pain and and things when you listen to
her music and it's like you almost kind
of took that on
when you were listening to it so you
know that that's maybe something to
consider too as well it's not just the
maybe just the rhythm or just the what
instruments are being used in it but
actually you know how was that created
and what's the sort of
um the spirit that was in that creator's
mind when they actually created that
music and
does that somehow influence or affect us
well remember earlier we were talking
about
music influx influence in our mood
so the creator of the music when they
are creating the music
they have to be in some type of mood
they make a conscious decision
on what they want their music to portray
how they want the music to affect the
listener
this is conscious it's it's not a
happenstance it's not a by the
by the way thing and so if the if the
the spirit of the music is for it
to induce anger in you when you listen
to it you will feel angry
if the person who's creating the music
um infuses a spirit
of pain and sorrow
you're going to feel that when you when
you listen
because music moves our emotions that's
right
in classical music is there a variety of
classical music that you would say is
maybe not as uh i'm trying to
choose my words carefully here because i
don't want to say it's like evil but
it's like maybe not as beneficial for
you to listen to as other ones like
there is that is why um
that is why the educational studies
specifically refer to mozart's music
as the mozart effect because
what they found is music that has
60 beats per second
most aligns with the brain so when the
the beat per second varies then you have
the
differing reactions on the brain and so
yes you have
classical pieces that are light and airy
and you do have classical pieces that go
the gamut of emotions that go into the
dark and deep areas
yeah yeah it works for for most
types of music i mean the heavy ra heavy
metal and rock music that's just it
it's just always kind of intense emotion
anger rebellion kind of thing but with
classical music there is
a variation maybe because of the
instrument because of the piano you can
actually piano or organ you can
get a variety of emotions there whereas
with
guitars and drums it's rarely restricted
in terms of the sounds that you get it's
interesting that they always speak of
rock as being
rebellion you know it's like the very
nature of how it's either put together
or what it really promotes or
i don't know it's just that rebellion
seems to go hand in hand with
with the rock world um
and i always just think like music is so
neat that it was created by god
that you play together with other people
and it's like everybody brings to the
table this like
little bit of a unique sound or a little
bit of a thing and when you put them
together it can make
beautiful music or you can have somebody
who's off
in a different sound and it's like the
more that that is offers the more that
someone's
you know screaming and it's not hitting
those notes right or something like this
it just seems so so much like a
metaphor for how we are in our world you
know it's like we either work together
or we're like
you know crashing and clanging up
against each other
and and sort of pitting each other
against you know
each other or what or we work together
it's actually a good
metaphor because when when one note of
the music
is off it brings discord
instead of harmony and the same thing in
life when certain things are
off then in the group or the community
then you get discord
or disharmony so um
in many christian churches the
type of music is changing or
has changed and it has become more
heavily rhythmic
that and less melody based i don't know
if you
have noticed that but in the church
circles where i go
that's what i have seen so many years
ago
when my daughter here was about seven
years old
i got tired of driving for 40 minutes
to the church that we used to attend and
i started searching around
for a church that was near a home but
one that had a
strong children's ministries department
and after searching for a while i found
one and it was only 10 minutes away from
me
and so we went there and it was really a
wonderful experience
when we started work when we started
worshiping there
they there was a a chorister one person
and there was a piano and an organ
we signed hymns we sang choruses we just
it was a very happy worship setting
and then over time over the over about
15 years of going there
the music just imperceptibly
changed until one day i noticed wait a
minute
the music is louder than the voices
and so when i started looking by then a
band had been developed one by one
little by little without
really making a public
statement they have been adding
instruments so
uh bass guitars have been added uh
rhythm
electric guitar had been added a
synthesizer
had been added a drum set had been added
um and it just became like wait a minute
when did we get this band that is so
loud music is supposed to accompany
voices but here
the voices were accompanying the music
and then most people had even stopped
singing
we were just listening to the music and
so
and it just seemed that from that point
of realization
every week the music got louder and more
secular
in in its in its tone if you were in the
foyer of the church and there was
singing going on or there was a
music experience happening
many times you couldn't tell the
difference between
the kind of music that would come from
a club and a church
if you couldn't hear the lyrics you
wouldn't know the difference
after a while i started going to church
with earplugs
so sort of the music started i just went
down low and stuck the plugs in my hair
and came back up and just
you know sat until it was was finished
at one point it got to the point where i
actually had to leave
i would leave the service and go walk
the neighborhood
until i thought the singing part was
ended and then come back
so which is actually quite interesting
because a lot of times don't you hear
people go to that worship service
because of the music
i hear that a lot from young people like
i want to go to church here because the
music
yeah and the same young people will tell
you
that the type of music they get in
church isn't different from the type of
music that they
listen to during the week so if if the
type of music is not different then
how is your life being changed how is it
influencing you
to draw closer to god so one day now i
was talking to the music director
i i mean he was a friend of mine and i
said to him you know
why have you changed the music so
drastically
you know what's the cause for this and
he said oh you know
it's okay to worship god according to
our culture
you know god god is acceptable of that
and i'm saying
our culture he's like yeah you know our
culture it's an african culture
we can worship god and i'm thinking but
i see that kind of music
in all churches regardless of the
culture
they've all moved in the same direction
that's true this is there's got to be
something
different not too long after that i was
blessed to
go we were blessed to go on mission
trips so we went to
seychelles and the seychelles is a group
of islands
east of kenya in the ocean the indian
ocean
so we went there we spent five weeks we
went to kenya
we spent a month we went to nigeria we
spent
well we went to nigeria twice one time
five weeks one time three
and what i noticed in most of the
all the churches we went to in
seychelles all the churches we went to
in kenya
there were no musical instruments except
for
sometimes a piano sometimes
an acoustic guitar one place there was
both a piano and an acoustic guitar
in nigeria all the churches except one
had no musical instruments or a piano
or an acoustic guitar and the one that
had drums was a mixed church where there
were students
on a campus a hospital campus and
i was told that the drums were brought
in because the students were mandated to
attend church and they came from so many
different
places and religions so i
i asked my host one of them i said you
know this is
africa how come you guys have no drums
in the church
and the man said to me and i'm going to
read a statement he said to me
drums are for voodoo ceremonies
not our church wow wow so
when you think about that well i guess
the answer is yes the drums
are a part of african culture but we can
compare that
to the food and african-american culture
if you remember
soul food what what are their meats
consisted of like the the neck
the intestines and the feet of the
animals when you look at history
slaves were eating that because that's
all they had access to that's what the
masters were giving them
so when people um the question is like
why are people still eating that today
when we have access to
more healthier options even though it's
it was a part of history our history so
when it comes to music and the things
that we have
learned how it affects the brain how it
affects the body
why are we holding on to certain
traditions and cultures when there are
more healthy or
uplifting choices out there yeah as soon
as you mentioned african culture
i was thinking like voodoo and stuff you
made a point though about how
less people were singing when the band
grew i saw that
uh me and some friends we we started
hosting this like once a month thing
called the hot spot we had
college kids come and the first night
was like 10 people and we just
sat in a circle and i shared my
testimony and
one of the guys playing acoustic guitar
and every person was singing i mean we
were
looking at each other and just acoustic
guitar and every voice was singing
but as it grew there was like a band
and it was just because we were looking
for music we didn't really
there was like one or two people that
played music but we were trying to look
for different people and
so people would be like oh we play and i
noticed that
when they'd be on stage when it when it
went from being a circle of everybody
looking to each other to rose looking at
the stage
nobody's saying nobody like not one
person they just watched the band like
it was a show
so that was interesting that you brought
that up i never really put the
connection to why
but i did bring it up i was like i like
when we did the circle i didn't know if
it was the circle or if it was the
but yeah it probably is the music it's
probably both yeah because the circle is
inclusive of everyone
but if you're sitting in rows the people
on the end they don't feel the same like
the people in the middle
yeah and all attention is up here yeah
yeah
yeah i remember reading an article a
gentleman wrote
about how music has become entertainment
and people no longer sing in churches
so he was looking at churches across a
number of denominations and what he was
saying
is when you bring the band in
i guess the our minds or we have been
socialized
into associating bands with
entertainment
so when you bring the band into church
and they play especially if they're
playing loud
and based on the genre that they're
playing in there's certain genres that
they just can't play soft
yeah they have to increase the volume so
it becomes
entertainment it's no longer inclusive
worship and that's why people stop
singing
because in their mind their brain tells
them this is entertainment
so what would you do in a concert you
sit and listen so if a concert
takes the place of the singing in your
church you sit and listen
i still think it's really interesting
that we use the term entertainment
and it's turning into that when enter
means to come in
tain means to you know possess and then
meant means to keep in that possession
and it's like to come in and possess you
and hold you in that state exactly
is what is very interesting
rather than you know i'm sure god
designed music for us to
join in together and and to share that
experience together and
yeah if you're interested to learn more
about what scotty just said about
entertainment and to delve deeper into
that check out our episode
called actors channeling spirits part
two
it's also a reinforcement because the
more people
have the mindset that they're being
entertained by music
the less people are singing the less
they're developing those skills
the less children are growing up with
that idea of playing instruments and
learning how to sing
and so you just reinforce not doing it
yeah um i didn't really grow up singing
so that's not a a strong
component in my life i i really struggle
with that you know i'm the guy that'll
make the joke about hey if you want
everybody to leave
just let me start singing
i would love to be able to play an
instrument but that was never part of my
growing up either but i'm trying to
provide that for my kids like my wife
grew up singing
she was in a choir she's she's good
and my kids are learning to play piano
and i got a daughter that plays violin
and all this i'm i'm trying to encourage
that because i see
if you don't encourage it it's going to
be lost and then it's not
his wife and children actually have a
gift like you can
sing a hymn song to them and they just
need to hear it once
and then they just will repeat it back
and sing it back it's pretty impressive
for me to
to observe because it's like you know
you i can hardly always remember the
hymns and like i can get the first you
know verses out and then
and then the rest i have to kind of like
look at it and read it but but you know
it's never too late to start something
yeah my problem now is time
okay because it's also mindset sometimes
we tell ourselves
i'm too old to do this no i don't think
i'm too old i would
love to pick up piano at any age that's
that's the instrument i think is for me
but i
just don't have the time to dedicate
that right now
when you hear things all the time like
you can't teach an old dog new tricks i
thought it was like true but i have a
friend
darius who was on the show he's i i've
since i've known him he can play guitar
and sing at the same time and i thought
i just assumed he's been doing this
since childhood he was like yeah once i
stopped
you know playing games and stuff like
that i just filled my time with
learning to play instrument he said i
just started playing guitar four years
ago i was like
four years ago you're my age
it was a shock to me yeah many of the
cliches we hear
actually lies all things in moderation
a little bit of heroin a little bit of
prostitution moderate yeah that was
actually my next question would you say
that
any type of music has its appropriate
time and place
to be put to good use i would say
any type of beneficial music okay has
its appropriate time and place because
different kinds of music
evoke different emotions but then we
want to
stay away that whole thing about
moderation that takes us to a
temperances
you know you do the good things in
moderation and you stay away
from the harmful things and so the same
applies to music
also appropriate situations yeah you
wouldn't go to a funeral and play
something super happy and lucky you know
like you'd that would maybe be a little
bit
inappropriate so i think the setting
really plays into
that as well i have a maybe
controversial
taboo question but i heard a pastor
saying like
certain music like arouses the
you know your body to move in a sexual
way or something and it's like
he's talking about how dancing is almost
like you see in the animal kingdom like
when one wants to mate
you know they do this dance and stuff
and uh so he was
he was generalizing that if you listen
to music that causes you to move
then people are going to start hooking
up and all this stuff but is that okay
in the marriage setting you know
like a husband and wife go in the room
and kenny g or whatever like you're
saying
well actually what he's saying is
scientifically proven i believe
genre different genres arouse certain
effects in people
and it has been shown that certain types
of rock music
and bring sexual stimulation um
and then country and western music it's
usually
love songs somebody's done somebody
wrong song
i lost my dog i lost my girl i lost
whatever
you know so yes that certain types of
music
do evoke sensual or sensuous
uh emotions in in people so
i guess it would be up to the couple if
they want to put on
some kennedy music and dance away in
their bedrooms or their living room
wherever
it's up to them but yeah i i would
caution
single people or you know christians
who congregate in places to play certain
types of music because
it's going to evoke certain emotions
that would just be contrary
to the will of god or the lord of god in
terms of
what plays out if you you give give
give way to the immune the emotion that
you are experiencing do you remember
when i was younger i was listening to
something but i forget what and you
asked me why you listening to that you
married
what does that have to do with it little
did i
you know yeah okay
you notice like whenever there's like a
cartoon and there's always like the
attractive woman comes in it's like
a saxophone or whatever always like they
don't even have to say anything that
music comes like you could be in the
other room and hear that you're like
what's going on in there
[Laughter]
yeah so you know there's there's a lot
that we can say on this whole
topic we can go into all different kinds
of
directions do we have musicologists
neuroscientists
and researchers they've all proven music
has effect has an effect
on various aspects of us as humans
and also other life forms not just us
many many people view it as
controversial
but music is not controversial
say that again many people view it as
controversial
but music is not controversial
it is not controversial at all it is
people who are controversial because of
sin
yeah i think there's actually certain
churches that just don't
bring instruments in or sing or anything
is that an extreme
or some church
maybe some some churches don't do any
instrumentation because of this type of
controversy because in any congregation
you have people who are
for the modernization of the music style
and you have people who are against
and it is it creates so much
conflict in a congregation i know
congregations that have split
wow because of the music music um
contradictions and arguments i remember
and being in south africa and
it was a congregation and they were
singing
acapella and it was as if i was standing
and listening to an organ
first off it was just like all-consuming
um everyone was like it seems like
perfect pitch and it was the most
beautiful thing i'd ever heard
and they were enjoying themselves and
they were just playing off of each other
in a sort of way and i it was yeah more
beautiful than any
band that i had heard that up until that
time i remember growing up
yes we did have an organ or a piano in
the congregation that i grew up in
but there were certain services where
there was no one to play it
and we just sang and you
you sang in different parts so you had
the sopranos and the altos and the
tenors and the basses
and everyone just sang their part and
the music was always so beautiful
but over time as as time
progressed and things got better
musical instruments were introduced and
it just
the nature of music of of the worship
service
itself changes based on the music
can i read to you a quote from confucius
sure
if one should desire to know whether a
kingdom is well governed
if its morals are good or bad the
quality
of its music will furnish the answer
there you go
so if you want to know whether a people
are governed by
good morals or bad morals study their
music and that will tell you
what that person is like it's amazing
that's interesting
and the opposite of that is also true i
can't remember the exact people but i've
listened to
interviews of musicians
and composers and they will tell you you
can change the moral standing
of of a group over time and they tell
you over how much time by changing their
music
so music is that powerful i remember
kanye west also talking about the devil
being the leader of the choirs
and that was one thing that he mentioned
in there and if you just think about
that thought
like he was the one that was closest to
god he understands the character of god
the best
and how do you how do you share that
character with other people
through music and stuff so naturally if
he really was the leader of the choirs
or whatever
he was designing that music he would be
in the best position to give that praise
to god
and yet if he knows that he knows how to
take you away from that the best no if
he does
he was created with music a part of his
system
and he was the choir director and that's
what he knows best
so what i remember everything that god
has created
the devil has created a counterfeit why
would
music be the exception and that's his
40.
why you know so we've looked at the
science
we've looked at culture what does the
bible say
about music can you give examples or an
example
of a musical scenario in the bible does
anyone remember one
well i know that nebuchadnezzar said of
a statue and
said that everybody had to bow at the
sound of the music and stuff so that's a
negative
so that's exactly good one is a good
example because
he played he said at the sound of the
music
bow down and worship so there he knew
that
word that music is integral to worship
and he knew that certain kinds of music
would make people
bow and so that would be the kind of
music
that he used i remember miriam after
the israelites crossed the red sea
she took her tambourine and started
dancing and singing
okay so there we have another one and
that would have been a different kind of
music
because now this is joyous happy music
celebration music
and they're dancing and this is a
different kind of dancing
because the different styles of music
evoke different
styles of dancing when you go to listen
to the rockets
in new york city at christmas time you
know they do the line dancing and the
foot kicking and stuff
you know just happy entertaining really
um fulfilling kind of of dancing
that's a different kind of dancing that
you would do to the kenny g
yeah really emotional kind of music yeah
moses taught the children of israel to
sing the ten commandments so
it was used as a teaching tool as well
yeah and that takes us back to
me learning the times tables singing
matthew 26 30 says and when they had
sung at hymn they went out to the mount
of olives this is after the last supper
okay so they had they had the last
supper they had a service asylum
service and they sang a hymn okay
so in in ephesians chapter 5 the second
part of verse 18
and verse 19 it says be filled with the
spirit
and that's the holy spirit speaking to
yourself
in psalms and hymns and spiritual
not carnal spiritual songs
singing and making melody in your heart
to the lord
now according to the scripture our music
must
align with what the lord considers
acceptable so if we're going to worship
god
then we need to do so with music that's
acceptable to him
and he gives us he's specific what he
wants us to use
psalms and hymns and spiritual songs
now did you notice that the
the aspect of music that had to do with
rhythm
is absent from that what does the verse
call
melody melody so music is made up of
melody which is the tune of the song
melody
by itself does have its own um tempo
beta rhythm then you have harmony where
you create parts that make the melody
more beautiful
so they cut yes they complement they go
together and they just create this
beautiful piece
in your ear and then you have rhythm
which is the beat
and that you can you can take the rhythm
of the music
you can vary it and you can create all
these different
types of emotions and reactions
but in music that's used for worship
god does not mention rhythm he talks
about melody
so could it be because the rhythm causes
listeners to
be consumed with their feelings and it
shuts down the judicious
thinking wow yeah because we have
we have research studies that show when
certain kinds of rhythms are used
the frontal lobe scary is shut down the
thinking part of your brain the
judicious part
the part that has to do with your
willpower and reasoning
it is shut down i was just thinking
about that
um because rhythm kind of takes over
like certain music's playing you might
not even be paying attention
you're tapping your toe to it bobbing
your head you're not even
thinking about it but god is so based on
free will
it's more satan's tactics to try and
brainwash propaganda
control whereas god's just like listen
to this beautiful music it might put you
in a good mood but it's not
making you move or it's not making you
do anything out of your will
whereas the rhythm you don't have
control over
that the secular songs i mean they they
say that the rhythm's gonna get you here
what's her name something esteban yeah
gloria yeah
she tells you and in a lot of the songs
they actually tell you what the music is
going to do to you
yeah she's like the rhythm is going to
get you and she's right when you listen
to that kind of music your feet start to
move by themselves you don't have any
evolution
it's just god is a very intentional god
so i could see how that would conflict
in the worship setting
to have that kind of rhythm because god
says come let us
reason together and if you're coming to
study the bible but you're full of
emotion i can see how some conflict
would be present there yeah because when
when there is high emotion
that goes into your limbic system that's
the feeling part of the brain
and you're thinking it's just shut off
just think about any any situation if
you get
highly emotional about something either
angry
or or um happy you can't think straight
so it's the same thing if the music is
evoking all of those
extreme emotions you won't be able to
think straight you won't be able to
reason with
the scriptures that you're reading you
you just won't and so we see a lot of
times now people
the attention services and they come
away there's no change in behavior
you don't see the effect of the sermons
that they're listening to all the time
and they will tell you
oh that was such a great sermon today
and what was the sermon about
oh i don't know i can't remember but i
know it was good
you know that's why because yes they
felt
the emotion while it was happening but
because their thinking process was shut
down
they don't remember same happens with
movies i mean i've done that walk out of
a theater and be like that was an
awesome movie and i'm like
man i really can't even tell you what
it's about really yeah and i think the
adverse
effect of that is is if you don't feel
something in a worship setting then it's
like well i didn't feel anything so
therefore it must not be you know so you
kind of walk away from it going
i just want to go somewhere where i feel
like i was impacted
you know you're sort of ordering your
life after the feelings not after the
you know the intellectual side like you
said and that's a caution right there
because god talks to us
on a reasoning level yeah he doesn't
want us to do things just because we
feel like it
and even so the words that we use when
we talk about worship are important
now you hear a lot of people talking
about the worship experience
at this church what is the worship
experience you know if i go to
worship why do i have to have a specific
worship
experience and so we just need to be
careful because words are also powerful
that's true
our words are powerful so if if
secular musicologists and
the neuroscientists they actually
acknowledge the power of instrumental
music
regardless of words shouldn't
christians pay attention to the type of
music that
actually happens during the worship time
absolutely especially if god specifies
it in his word
no yeah so you guys know jimi hendrix
right
so this is what he said music is a
spiritual thing
of its own you can hypnotize people
with the music and when you get them at
their weakest point
you can preach into their subconscious
what you want to say other other
musicians have said similar things
madonna and stuff says
says that yeah it's like a sermon or
whatever
yeah carlos santana i talked about that
experience as well
they know what they're doing it's it's
not
it's it's not um random they do know
it's the listener who doesn't know well
the uninformed
listener doesn't know um the
this university music professor called
dr michael balam
he agrees with hendrick's statement he
actually says
the human mind shuts down after
three or four repetitions of a rhythm
or a melody or a harmonic progression
so whether it's the regular good part
the melody and the harmony
or the rhythmic part which can be used
to influence you
anytime you have repetitions beyond
three or four
your mind shuts down so that goes into
what
hendrick says you're hypnotized i
remember
a musician watching a presentation on
musician one time and
they played a hem using like the
chords that were with the hem and then
they just shifted the chords to use like
the seventh and thirteenths and
like like different sounds and it
totally changed the way that the
that the hem was like sounding i mean it
was really interesting
and when you'd play both ways i mean you
could notice right off the bat that
there's more here than just the words
you know
there's there's something else like that
that goes along with those
notes yeah that's syncopation because
when when you have
standard music goes on a four-fourth
beat
and so you have the accent on the first
and the third
so you have you sing a song
onward christian soul just
you have the the accent or the emphasis
on those beats
and when they when they play with that
and they move the accents
to the third or the second and the
fourth beat
they that's what syncopation is and what
actually happens
is it puts off the rhythm of your brain
and so it actually moves into the
decision-making process
people make wrong decisions when their
brain is not
functioning in properism so
that's why music is so powerful it can
actually
influence you to do something that you
wouldn't normally do
under regular circumstances i remember
who it was i wish i knew the exact
reference it would be a lot better but
there was like a
a classical musician and his family
to wake him up they would like he'd be
upstairs in his bed and and they would
go to the piano and they'd play part of
a song and just
not do the last note and it would drive
him so crazy he'd get up out of bed and
go ping
and do the last note but it woke him up
like he couldn't
sit there and lay there knowing that
that last note wasn't played i'm gonna
try that thank you
you have to be sure how musical they are
yeah
yeah so we talked about before man when
lucifer was created how he was created
as a musical being
today satan's master plan is to deceive
and distract god's people in subtle ways
that will stunt the spiritual growth
so we shouldn't feel discouraged or
despondent or defeated anyway because
the same supreme being god
who gave lucifer those gifts
is the embodiment of music
amen and he has provided us with healthy
choices
so here's the good news since we have
the capacity to be self-directed
yeah we can choose
the kind of music we listen to we can
choose music that dispels
negative passions and encourages
positive emotions
thus we can contribute to our optimal
health
both the physical health and the mental
and also as we worship we can choose
appropriate music
that aligns with god's word so we know
that our worship will be acceptable
to him for example hymns are great
when i listen to instrumental music
one of my favorite pianists is
kendall bacchus the lively acapella
music is another
option that you can choose i enjoy its
mute its melody
i just appreciate the harmony that that
comes
into it and there's good contemporary
gospel music also and
one of the the musical groups that comes
to mind
is the collins worth family
so i encourage you today audience to
use the principles we've discussed
to guide your decisions as you seek to
glorify god
in your musical choices well
um this was fantastic mom thank you so
much for presenting and sharing all this
information with us
and we hope that that gave you a
foundation to go out and research more
and study more
um they're just there's so much out
there it's such a heavy topic we could
have three four
five parts to it but here's a challenge
to you all
we'd like you to write in the comments
section uh what your favorite
style of music is or maybe your favorite
artists where we're really trying to
grow a community here
to help each other so we can all learn
and grow together if you have any
questions or comments at all leave that
in the comments section if you like the
video please like
comment subscribe share this to your
friends and family
and we will see you next week on led
[Music]
live
you